[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing another exciting what if
scenario for the wizarding world
what if dudley dursley harry potter's
volatile cousin had turned out to be a
wizard too
now although the mere idea of this
what-if scenario might have you
immediately spewing profanities my way
you must admit that the chance that
dudley might have possessed some magical
talent is not all that far-fetched of an
idea
why is that you may ask well to start
with it's common knowledge that plenty
of witches and wizards are born into
muggle families in which no other known
relatives possesses the ability to
perform magic
which of course brings us to my second
point this is the exact situation lily
evans harry's mum found herself in
as you likely well know lilly's family
was comprised entirely of muggles
including her sister petunia dudley's
mum
and although in adulthood petunia showed
nothing but disdain for her sister's
magical talents even going so fast to
call her a freak we know from flashbacks
of the girl's childhood that petunia
actually rather envied lilly's abilities
and had wished to attend hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry herself
in fact as a child she even sent a
letter requesting admission to professor
dumbledore
sadly yet very understandably petunia
was gently let down by dumbledore who
could not allow admission of a muggle to
the school
unfortunately this only seemed to spurn
her jealousy of lily into blatant hatred
and resentment
but alas i digress
in any case it's completely within
reason to consider the possibility that
dudley dursley son of vernon and petunia
dursley very well could have been born a
wizard
of course we all know that this didn't
happen but what if it had
i think the most obvious question that
must first be addressed is how mr and
mrs dursley would have taken the news
so intense were they on preventing harry
from receiving his letter of acceptance
from hogwarts one must wonder if they
would have done the same if their son
was also bound for the magical school of
witchcraft and wizardry would vernon and
petunia have hidden away dudley's
letters alongside harry's would they
have maintained that the wizarding world
was full of freaks and certainly not to
be trusted or by merlin's beard would
they have been proud of their son
perhaps if dudley had turned out to be a
wizard that would have changed vernon
and petunia's entire perspective on
magic
from petunia's view if her son had been
a wizard and received his letter
welcoming him to hogwarts the very
school that had projected her decades
before maybe she would have felt some
sort of validation however even if they
had openly accepted dudley's letter to
hogwarts there's a large part of me that
thinks they still would have gone to the
same great length that they did in the
actual series to prevent harry from
receiving his
that is they would have handed over
dudley's but continued to withhold
harry's
i mean they struck me as petty enough
that even if their son was indeed
magical they would have still felt the
need to put harry down and to not
acknowledge that he too was a wizard
there's also the idea that vernon and
petunia had chosen to hide both boys
letters to hogwarts and had still ended
up in that isolated location where they
foolishly thought they could hide from
the mail
hagrid would have still come for harry
as he does in the actual series
and despite not being particularly fond
of dudley as i'm sure you remember the
pig's tale he gave him for eating
harry's birthday cake i do believe that
hagrid would have felt duty-bound to
bring dudley along with him and harry to
hogwarts
so regardless of how mr and mrs dosley
felt about dudley being a wizard i
believe that one way or another he would
have gone to hogwarts
that is even if fernan and petunia had
been hell-bent on preventing him from
learning magic and attending the school
dudley still would have made it there
just like harry did
which brings us to my speculations on
what at least time at hogwarts would
have been like
to start with i find it hard to believe
that dudley and harry would not have sat
together on the hogwarts express
i mean true they didn't like each other
all that much but imagine being in a
completely foreign place in which you
know very little of how things work
i'm fairly confident that you'd stick
pretty close to anyone you were even
remotely familiar with so if the two
boys were sitting together on the train
only to then be joined by ron weasley
how would that first train ride have
gone would harry have offered to pay for
snacks for the whole lot of them with
his newfound fortune or would he have
kept quiet so as not to have to share
with dudley
from what we know of harry's personality
he likely would have offered to purchase
food for all of them wouldn't he and so
perhaps this would have been the first
of many more positive interactions
between the cousins once they'd arrived
at hogwarts however i don't think they
would have stayed together all that long
since i'm pretty convinced that dudley
desley would not have been a gryffindor
true he does possess some
characteristics of the scarlet and gold
house for example acting before thinking
and later in the series dudley even
shows some bravery when he stands up for
harry against his parents
overall though i think that he would
have been better suited to a different
house
you may be thinking that he obviously
would have been sorted into slytherin
but i'm not so convinced i mean of
course as a child he's little terror who
seems to strongly resemble draco
malfoy's lackeys crab and goyle
yet i think the sorting hat is a lot
more intuitive than that it takes into
account not only who a young witch or
wizard is at the age of 11
but also who they have the capacity to
be
with all that in mind i must admit that
i rather think dudley would have been
sorted into hufflepuff
he's not the cleverest which matches
well with this house being reserved more
for ravenclaw and he proves to be rather
hard working going after things that
he's interested in such as his passion
for boxing
think two on the fact that hufflepuffs
are known to always have good snacks
with their common room being located
right by the hogwarts kitchen
and of course our dear dudley had a
reputation for his love of food i also
think the earlier example i mentioned of
dudley standing up for harry
showcases his strength in loyalty
another quality associated with
hufflepuff so with dudley and hufflepuff
i think it would have been a nice
balance for the two cousins that is they
would have been part of the same world
learning magic but not side by side
perhaps this would have helped foster a
friendly relationship between harry and
dudley
similar to the one we see start to
emerge later in the actual series
with a much improved relationship with
harry and dudley possessing the ability
to do magic i wonder if this would have
led to dudley being involved in harry's
many adventures over the year
or if he would have remained a more
peripheral character
in my opinion if he and harry were to
come around to the point of being
friendly to one another he likely would
have had some involvement over the years
at the very least near the end of the
series when harry goes off to hunt
horcruxes
and since something like dumbledore's
army involves students from almost every
hogwarts house i think this is one such
plot line that would have definitely
altered to include dudley if he was also
a wizarding student at the school
side note in terms of personal interests
i'm not convinced that dudley would have
made the hufflepuff quidditch team but
if he did i think he likely would have
been one of the beaters i mean can't you
just see him swinging one of those bats
at the bludgers his face filled with
glee
all in all i truly believe that if
dudley had been a wizard it would have
done great things for his personal
growth and his relationship with harry
being away from vernon and petunia
forming friendships with people outside
of where he grew up would have likely
helped shape him into a decent and loyal
young man from an earlier age
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think do you
agree with what i've suggested in this
what-if scenario or do you think that
dudley's relationship with harry would
have remained strained even if he'd been
a wizard or perhaps you think that he
would have become best mates with draco
and ended up in slytherin let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
you're a wizard dudley
[Music]
you